I think it's haunted before when we
introducing solid to your induction
right in Dutch this method okay and we
started off with proving things I hear a
little from the David so we look the
series because that was velocity like
that fix it you're familiar with but
things to do a series and of the
algebraic identities like that really
one with the UM you know the prompt I
think it was or is it you know K plus
the time n plus 1 n plus 2 and so on
right and now we're going on something
else that's a lot of series but I told
algebra really okay it's just showing
that this law we make without painting
that I use your hand okay integer values
now we're going to do this morning this
is look this is about one two three
three kinds of proof
yes entirely different geography once to
this one I was gonna write use the
principle of mathematical induction
this leave it off because when you look
at the question how would you approach
it sure like it you know you seven right
you sort of don't know what else to do
so you just sort of try things right you
just put numbers in and you're like ah
they really do all work right but then
proof by example with my example is not
a valid way of proof right because you
can find a few that work and then a
whole bunch of the done right and the
ones that work don't mean that they work
so how we're going to use induction for
this it's also tricky to because there's
no statements like something equals
something else right and you can start
with the math straight away there's no
equation for you it's actually so we
have to make one okay so how are we
going to do this this let's start off
with our little ball four steps test
assume prove explain okay and then we'll
see what kind of of
along the way first thing I've test now
I haven't given one but what do you
think is the festival value I guess
because if you put in sewer right
you'd get 3 to the 0 minus 1 which is 1
minus 1 which is 0 and then I have 2
visibility was zero zero is it a trees
anyway so we're getting FN equals 1
there's our first value okay
yeah spices got never made it right here
it's did this with my everything but
then it's a bit depressing because like
you know divisions about sharing things
right it's like you can all share
nothing so the left-hand side is equal
to 3 to 4 which is 81 ok good
and that's 80 sorry that's one and
that's okay now I said left hand side
it's kind of right hand side who is
there right so I would just say this is
divisible by 80 so therefore it's true
for N equals 1
now we're going to make an assumption
but the Assumption would have to be in
some kind of equation so that I could
take that and then sub it into the next
thing and then it also to play out at
least I heard right but what will I
assume right assume the statement is
true for N equals K okay so the first
part just sticking the K is not so hard
3 to the power 4 K whatever K happens to
be minus 1 this number should be
divisible by 80 right so what would it
equal how would you say you got
something over here
it must be always to this way whatever
the number is why me do some of my 80
the multiples 881 60 to 40 and so on
what do they have in common right well
they're all a multiplied by an integer
right I'm some whole number so I could
say 80 multiplied by another so what was
I actually specify that that number is
an integer
what this means is pick up one two three
four five six any kind of value in that
range and so eighty times that number
that's a definite event invincible okay
so this part here is crucial
it's it's really our starting point and
now we can actually start to work with
this okay
so step three let's do a pretty prove
for the next value okay what's gonna
this gonna look like ie
three to the power of four
now again be careful don't go for k plus
1 right because there be four times k
plus one near brackets right so I'm
gonna put k plus four minus one now what
will I put on the right-hand side
I probably shouldn't put a teepee right
because if I just assume this I assume
if I go up and multiply by something
bigger right it's not gonna be eight
times the same number
okay so I guess I wanted to do something
else
letter after P is to you I suppose I
just have to distinguish it's just in
another poster
okay now perform I'll show you how this
all works you have a go okay I know I
haven't shown you I can still play it
does look a little bit different from it
so it's not quite as intuitive as the
ones you've done already but try it see
if you can get to the end and see
there's a there's an inside which has to
do with what you're trying to prove okay
so keep that ago